I'm John Strowmire and I'm a troop order of the Arrow Representative Advisor with
Troop 55 in Houston, Texas. This edition of the Scoutmasters podcast is
sponsored by backers like me. Carl, thanks so much for all you do with the podcast.
And now to you, Scoutmasters.
Don't know what the weather's been like where you are, but we had a really warm
winter around here so far. so when we got out camping this past weekend, it
was really good and cold- finally Real winter, you know. And we had a problem
because our campfire froze. but what you know, what you do if that happens, is you
chip off the frozen flames, put them in your pockets. they'll warm up and keep
you nice and cozy. It works every time, Really. Hey, this is podcast number 299..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look at
the mailbag, see what's going on. Well, one message made into the mailbag this
weekend is from Terry Dutton, who is the Scoutmaster of Troop 16 in Oak Park,
Illinois, And Terry said: thank you. I couldn't agree more That STEM as a
standalone concept really isn't going to work in scouting. And Terry's referring
to our last podcast, number 298, where I answered an email question from a
venture crew advisor who said, you know, they were kind of putting STEM at the
center of the program and trying to figure out how to work the patrol
method into that. And I said: well, you know, there's some aspects that you can
work into it, but you got to look at this. Scouting is designed to be an
outdoor program of camping and adventure and things like that, And when
you try and put these other things at the center of the program it really
becomes kind of problematic. So, Terry, at least Terry agrees with me. Let's
see. We finally got back to having some live chats. this past week on
Tuesday and Wednesday mornings Had a lively group with a lot of our
frequent fliers showing up to share some time on the live chat with us, And we
also welcomed Francis Gee, who's from Liverpool in the UK And he's just
taken over as a scout leader after being an assistant for a couple of
years. So, Francis, so glad that you could come and join us. If you want
to join in on one of our live chat sessions, keep an eye on the
Facebook feed and our Twitter feed, where I'll announce that we're
going to be live over at scoutmastercgcom, Usually Tuesday
mornings and Wednesday mornings Eastern time. So check in, join the
chat. Next week is my heavily promoted 300th edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast. It'll be, I think. what is it? It's going to
be five or six years since we started the podcast And I've
got a few things to announce for you next week. But let me
remind you this week that the reason that we're still here, the
reason we're still recording podcast, is because of the
generosity of our backers. Backers are folks who make a one time
kind of voluntary subscription payment, And that covers the
expense of producing and publishing. what you find on
scoutmastercgcom. That's all the blog posts, infographics,
everything that we work with, the videos, And it also includes
what you're listening to right now. So what I need you to
do is to go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support
link at the top of the page, and you'll find a number of
options that will make you a scoutmastercgcom backer. And
this week I want to personally thank Joyce Swenson, James
Peterson, Donald Chen and Ray Chung, who have become
backers since our last podcast. Once again, it's pretty
easy to do: Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the
support link at the top of the page, become a backer this
week and I'll make sure to thank you during our next
podcast. Well, in this week's podcast. I have some email
questions to answer and a very short reminder for all of
us in scoutmastership in seven minutes or less, And that's
going to take up the remainder of the podcast. So let's
get started, shall we Scouts master ship in seven
minutes or less. You know it was good old Ralph
Waldo Amerson who said: patience and fortitude
conquer all things. That's an especially important
thought for us as scouts, because scouting can be- oh it
can be- a little frustrating at times, can it Even
irritating, And our scouts can be a little irritating And
the situations that we find ourselves in can be a little
frustrating. And going back over 30 plus years of being a
scouter, I'm real happy to report that it seems to
me. it seems to me that pretty much the days of the
really kind of aggressive shouting scoutmaster are in
the past. That kind of drill sergeant, loud, overbearing,
adult presence that used to be far more common than it is
right now has diminished, And that's a good thing, Because
if you're going to shout or yell at scouts, it not
only is very upsetting for them, it's also portrays a
certain weakness of character on your part too. Yelling
is really an irrational, impulsive reaction, And
I've had plenty of chance to study this kind of thing
because I'm a bit of a hothead myself and I can find
myself yelling and kind of losing my temper pretty
easily. Maybe you share that particular character
flaw with me, maybe you don't, but it's, it can be.
it can be a very difficult thing to come to terms
with And you have to remind yourself that that
kind of verbal explosion, that kind of letting your
temper get the better of you, is no less appropriate
than like lashing out at people physically, And it
can do as much harm you know emotionally to
people as it can to just lash out physically at
them. So I still have a long way to go on this
personally. but bringing a bad temper under
control means you first you kind of have to
recognize what triggers a loss of temper and then
disarm all those triggers by doing something
simple like taking a few deep breaths or counting
to ten and break the chain of impulse to
reaction. I mean walk away from the situation,
gain a little control and perspective, because
trivial things are often the most upsetting.
That's what I find anyways. And if you have a
child in scouts they can do trivial things in
the perspective of other people who may be
observing that- that are very upsetting to
you. And what I have to say to you is, like
I said, you know, control the impulse to
react, step away, count to ten, take a few
deep breaths. And it's doubly difficult to do
if we're tired and stressed And if you're a
volunteer scouter, there are going to be
plenty of opportunities to be tired and
stressed. One of the more difficult times for
me was always when we were packing up on a
Sunday after a weekend camping trip. Now,
simple things, really simple things, like the
way to put away a tent or cleaning up a
cook at very trivial stuff. But after,
after about 30 years of, you know, constantly
reminding scouts of they got to do these
things properly, I can lose my temper over
those trivial things on a Sunday where maybe
I got a good sleep last night, maybe I
didn't, Maybe I'm feeling rested and calm
and assured and ready, Maybe I'm not. I
have to stop and remind myself of what
good old Ralph Waldo said: Patience and
fortitude conquer all things. Got to be
patient. And being patient also includes
the idea that as scouts- depending on the
age group that we're working with- a lot
of time our time is spent in observing and
stepping back, And the impulse to step
in and correct and instruct or react
can be kind of overpowering, especially
if our own children are involved again.
And the difference between a really great
scouter and one who just does the job
well is in replacing our initial impulse
to react with a lot of advice and a lot
of talking and stepping in and saying.
let me show you how to do it with a more
rational and studied view of the
situation, in which we let the scouts
discover things for themselves. So
remember what Ralph said: patience and
fortitude. conquer all things. Apply
those, gain some perspective, separate
yourself from triggering situations where
you could fly off the handle a little
bit and understand that that kind of
patience and fortitude also extends to
resisting the impulse to react and to
talk scouts to death about every
single little thing.
I want to jump up and scream and shout it out.
I can do it if I do it, if I want.
Cause baby, I was born to be a scout.
Here comes the scout. master,
Driver, jump, the scout will be a little faster.
Stick on the gas. are we there yet?
I want to build a bridge for my equal project.
Find me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So we had some email questions come in
over the past week or so, Heard from Craig
Snodgrass who's a scout master, troop one
in Altadena, California, and he said this:
I'm a relatively new scout master- This is
the ninth month I've been doing this-
but I did spend a few years as an
assistant cub master and cub leader.
my predecessor ruled the annual
planning process and got some input
from the patrol leaders council but didn't
really invest them in the process.
He planned three major things beyond the
meetings that we have every month.
One was a day event and that was
intended to be a alternative if a
scout missed getting out on the overnight.
The other one was the overnight itself
And the third thing was a monthly
service project to kind of balance out
the outdoor program. At present our
patrol leaders council seems to
struggle with focus on the monthly
overnighters and they're also trying to
juggle these two other things- a service
project and a day event- and I'd like
your opinion on whether planning for
all those three sounds about right for
a patrol leaders council or does it
sound like too much for them to do.
Just so you know, in the past
eight service projects, we
averaged around 20%, or just
under six, of our 28 scouts
participating. If I look at attendance
for overnight's day, hikes and troop
meetings, about six of our scouts
attend everything, another
nine attend about 50%
of everything and the remaining 13
get to about 20%
of everything. Well, Craig, if I read
things right here, about half
of your scouts are participating in
any of these events about 20%
of the time, Which would make me
ask the question: why
is there so little participation in these
things? So let's zoom out. Instead
of asking what planning expectations
of the patrol leaders council ought to be,
let's ask why you're planning things
that scouts are apparently not very interested
in doing or you're having real participation
lags in. What I
think is going to be useful for you is not just
me laying out procedural steps
or giving you a bunch of advice.
that's not going to be very useful.
What you need to do, I think, is
to start thinking about the bigger ideas
in the real heart of why
you're doing what you're doing as a scouter,
And once you have that kind of established
in your mind, everything else is
relatively light. lifting The first place
to begin thinking about this is that
scouts need to do what
scouts do. We don't want to start with
a set of standards or measurements.
We don't want to start with the journey to excellence
and look at those measurements and say, well, that's
what we should be doing. We want to start
with the idea that scouts are going to develop
character by applying the patrol
method And if we're doing that
quickly, the resulting metrics
are going to match
the indicators in something like
the journey to excellence program. But
we don't start with the indicator and build
from there. We start with doing what
scouts do. That's the principle.
If we get ourselves caught
in this kind of thicket of policies, procedures
and logistics, we're coming at the whole
thing from the wrong direction. All
of these things make sense
when we very simply
do what scouts do.
When scouts do the things that scouts do,
they develop character as an
after effect. If we try to
develop character in object lessons and
sermons, we miss the more powerful
experiential opportunities.
A campfire is worth
a thousand words.
The experience of going out and camping
with your patrol is worth a hundred
sermons. The other interesting thing
that happens is when scouts do the things
that scouts do, they advance as an after
effect. When scouts
do the requirements, they can check things
off in a book, but understanding
the concepts and the
skills are worth
much more than checking them
off in the book. right, And if they're
doing the things that scouts do, if
they're going camping, if they're doing
service projects, if they're getting
together, if they're working within the
patrol system, they do all the
requirements as an after effect.
So the answer to your question
isn't really about how many things you
plan and who should be planning them. The
real answer is another question:
are you doing the things that
scouts do? Because
if you do that, I guarantee a few things:
You'll meet the metric
indicators of success, your
scouts will advance, you'll see your participation
numbers grow and your patrol
leaders council will be very motivated
about planning and making those things happen.
I expand on the whole idea of doing
things scouts do in a post
at scoutmastercgcom
that are interestingly titled
Do What Scouts Do, and I'll have a link
to that post in the podcast
notes. Paul Teal is the
scoutmaster for our troop 825
in Houston, Texas
and he wrote in to say this:
our patrol leaders council recently
reviewed position descriptions.
they have had a difficult time understanding
the differences between the instructor
and the troop guide. Is
there a difference between those two positions
of responsibility and do we
need both? Most of the guidance I've been
able to find, say, the troop guide is
focused on the new scout patrol
and we don't really use the new scout patrol.
Once again, what's
the difference between those positions of responsibility,
and must we have them or
do we really need them?
Well, Paul, I would think of positions of responsibility
and scouting, as you would the player positions
on an athletic team. For example,
basketball employs
the traditional positions of a point guard,
two wings and two post players,
and the designations of those positions
are helpful
in developing a strategy
to play the game, but if you check,
they're not mandated by basketball rules
and some coaches even
ignore of identifying people
by those positions. altogether, It all
depends on what kind of strategy they're using
to play the game. Once you start
looking at things from that perspective,
I think the whole idea of
the way positions of responsibility
work tend to become a little
more clear. Now, do you
need to have instructors or troop guides?
must you have them? No, you don't
have to have either if they're not
perfect to your team strategy.
As we all know, scouts have to occupy a position
of responsibility to satisfy the
tenure requirement from rank, but there's
no absolute definition
of exactly what those roles are
or how they are fulfilled.
Positions of responsibility are only
defined to serve the needs
of your scouts, not
a limitation about how they ought to
be doing things. Once again, look
back at basketball, right,
Your point guard, your wings, your
post players. well, you know
certain strategies. they're going to be doing different
things, aren't they? So I would
be very reticent to tie anybody's
hands by giving everyone a
precise,
universal job description
for each one of those positions of responsibility,
because, first of all, they're not
jobs. Our scouts are not employees.
we're not employers.
Our scouts are not soldiers, we are not generals.
There is not
a set of standing orders that
scouts have to memorize
and repeat to us, right?
We're playing a lively game,
And so the idea of positions of responsibility
are going to shift around a little bit.
There's no use to have them in some
hidebound description that
limits the ability of your patrol
leaders council to get the job done
and do the things that scouts do.
Well, that being said,
let's also agree that
there's some wisdom in the way
that these positions of responsibility
are defined and the
traditional roles that we use
in scouting. And again, if you
hark back to basketball, well you know there's
some wisdom in the idea of having a point guard
and wings and things like that.
Just because it's traditional doesn't mean
that is bad, And just like a basketball
coach is going to find those ideas useful,
a scouter and their youth
leaders are going to find the traditional
roles useful. I mean, a troop
can't really operate very well without
the key youth positions of patrol leaders,
and if there are enough patrols of having a senior patrol
leader and the other positions are there
to help the scouts define
a leadership team and a strategy
for their troop. They're not
as a requirement that each of those positions
be filled. I'll tell you that
we've never used the troop guide or instructor
positions during my time as scout master,
and we also never really had anything
like a librarian historian, webmaster,
chaplain, aide, OA representative
or a leave no trace trainer.
It's not that those roles wouldn't be valuable
in some situations. We just never saw a need
for them ourselves.
We never really used the new scout patrol model
either. I think we had some pretty
successful years, though, and we always
approached the youth leadership aspect
of things and positions of responsibility
from less
of a strict definition
of exactly what all those roles had to be,
to the idea that
there was a leadership team
whose strategy would shift depending on what
they needed to accomplish.
This email came in a little while back from James Longo,
who's with troop 228
in Rockford Michigan.
He said: I've taken over as the troop committee chair
and we've had some people step down
and others planning on stepping down,
one of those being the treasurer.
I've asked a couple of people and
emailed people and so far
I have had zero luck
replacing the treasurer.
Are there any rules in place that say
a chairman, a committee chairman,
cannot be the treasurer as well?
I was thinking if I offered to do
both jobs, maybe somebody
would finally speak up and take over
the treasurer's work.
Well, James, there's nothing that I ever found
that says you can't be the troop treasurer
and the troop committee chair at the same time.
but boy, what a rotten bad
idea that would be.
I would avoid doing it at all costs.
Naturally, you're a nice guy and you'll do
anything to help, and that made you
into a committee chairman.
That's the kind of person you are.
What you have to ask yourself is
when too much is going to be too much,
because most of the people I know
who volunteer in scouting, especially
in the more important roles,
are willing to give themselves
to the point of burning themselves out,
and that's a pretty common thing that happens.
so you have to identify some limitations
for yourself.
So if you take on the treasurer thing
and the committee chair at the same time,
there is no way
you're going to get anybody else to step up
to be the treasurer, because the job is already being done
and it's very likely you're going to end up
taking on other roles that other
people should have. The idea that
taking it on will inspire someone else to take
the job is a reflection of
your very hopeful
outlook. but
I've got to tell you it's
probably mistaken. It's more likely.
it's going to be a great relief to everybody
that James decided to do it. That means
that lets us off the hook.
It's really not going to inspire them.
It's going to send a very clear message that James
will do it if nobody else does.
There's really no temporarily
taking up a position like this.
and I'll say again, if you take it on,
it's going to be doubly difficult
to find someone to take it over.
If I was in your situation, I'd simply
tell everybody on the committee that unless somebody
steps up and takes on the role,
there's not going to be any way to cut checks
or receive payments or manage the accounts
for the truth, and that part
of things will grind to a halt and it will be
very difficult to do much scouting without those
things happening. So unless somebody
thinks this is important, things are going
to simply be left undone.
No camping this month. We don't have a treasurer
to collect fees or sign checks. That sounds
a little harsh, but that is the actual
reality. If there's no treasurer,
things are not going to happen. So somebody
needs to look at this as being important.
if I was a committee chair, I would also
have a one hat policy,
No dual roles.
If no one will take on a role, that means
it's not important enough to anybody and
everything grinds to a halt associated
with that role. And when that kind of thing
happens, usually the response is
is somebody says: oh,
oh, now I understand
this is really important
and I'll take it on. I hope that helps. James,
Listen, if you have a question for me, you can
get in touch with me. it's very simple to do
and we're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
Thanks so much for listening to this
299th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
I promise to tell you how to keep in touch.
the first way is to make sure to go visit
scoutmastercgcom, where you can
read the blog and you can
subscribe to receive updates to the
blog and the podcast by email.
We're all over social media and a lot
of people follow us that way.
There are more than 11,000 folks
like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
there's over 1,300
tweeters on Twitter.
There's over 400 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest.
You can also see us
over at ScoutmasterCG on
YouTube, but I understand
there's a lot of people who can't
Facebook and Twitter makes them better.
They have no interest in Pinterest.
They certainly don't put you in YouTube,
but that's just fine by me.
You can zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email.
You can get in touch with me at-
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
Now, if none of those ways work,
look around your stately manor home
and you'll find a bronze bust
of Shakespeare. There's a button inside
that will open a secret passageway.
slide down the bat pole in that passageway
and I'll be waiting for you in the bat cave
to answer all of your questions.
By now it should be abundantly clear that
none of this- the Scoutmaster blog,
the Scoutmaster podcast or any of the stuff that we do-
are official publications of anybody
in particular other than myself.
They're not endorsed or sponsored by anyone
like the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization.
No, it's just me. I somehow
found a microphone and a way to get on
the internet and people listen to me.
How about that?
But we're just trying to lend a hand to
Scoutleaders and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Palin. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.